globotech Industries is a multinational
conglomerate that specializes in
manufacturing high quality military
hardware recently they have acquired a
toy company Heartland Play Systems with
the mission of integrating Battlefield
technology into it in the opening scene
heartland's head toy designers Irwin and
Larry have a meeting with the board
members of globotech the CEO Gil Mars is
interested in hearing their thoughts on
their newest projects which involve the
development of intelligent interactive
toys nervous Irwin offers the gorgonites
peaceful beings led by a character named
Archer whose mission is to gather
information about Earth Larry on the
other hand swiftly introduces the
Commando Elite a special task force of
action figures led by chip Hazard
despite Irwin's protests Mars selects
the hideous gorgonites as the Commando
Elites adversaries and assigns them a
three-month deadline to complete their
entire project Irwin deems it impossible
due to the extensive testing and design
time required but they have no choice
but to proceed after the meeting a woman
hands the designers their security cards
and unique passwords to the company's
online account she instructs them to
keep their passwords confidential but
Irwin reads his aloud immediately later
that night Larry attempts to access the
company's account but cannot recall his
password as a result he enters Irwin's
password in order to look for internal
parts he then orders thousands of
military-grade microprocessor chips
oblivious to the consequences eventually
the new toy line is finished and ready
for shipment the subsequent scene
introduces us to a school boy named Alan
Abernathy and his family who owns an out
of favor traditional toy store the
store's business is on the brink of
collapsing due to low sales when Alan's
father Stewart is called away on a
business trip he entrusts Alan with the
store hoping he will prove his
worthiness and also because he's a
stereotype bumbling 90s father and he's
in absolute danger to himself and
everyone around him one day as Alan
takes care of the store a Heartland
trucker arrives and the delivery driver
Joe allows him to sign for several
shipments while doing so Alan notices
some boxes of Commando Elite and
gorgonite toys intended for a larger
store and decides to take a look at them
to his surprise when the toys are taken
out of their boxes they become animated
and begin to wage war against each other
Ellen believes that the toys have been
designed extremely well so he persuades
Joe to leave him a complete set of each
group hoping to boost the store's
fortunes although Joe initially refuses
Alan's please eventually convince him to
relent nothing better go wrong or it's
my ass kid says Joe right before
everything goes wrong while the new toy
sets are being loaded inside Alan's
neighbor and romantic interest Christy
fimple comes in with her younger brother
Timmy to pick out a toy for his birthday
upon browsing The Boy comes across the
feuding toys in the back room Timmy is
so impressed that he begs his sister to
buy him one Christy finds it a bit
expensive but nonetheless she reserves
chip Hazard for her brother just then
her boyfriend arrives to pick her up and
seeing this Alan is butt hurt hence he
quickly closes the shop and heads home
later while working on a school
assignment Allen discovers the leader of
the gorgonites Archer inside his
backpack it turns out the toy had
sneaked inside one of the pockets
earlier when Alan activates it Archer
responds by repeating his name the
teenager finds it shocking but he
concludes that he's simply seeing things
because of a tiring day at work so he
returns to his schoolwork and eventually
falls asleep in the meantime Archer
comes to life access is Alan's computer
and searches for information on a place
called Gorgon Allen also awakens and
discovers that Archer is actually a real
life toy with its own mind they
introduce themselves to each other
formally and Archer mentions that their
sole goal is to free the gorgonites
meanwhile at the toy store chip Hazard
breaks free from his packaging and
activates the other members of the
Commando Elite which includes Kip
killigan brick bazooka Butch meat hook
Nick Nitro and Link static following
this they embark on their mission to
exterminate all gorgonites the following
morning Allen discovers the store in
disarray with all of the new toy sets
missing all they find are the shattered
remains of one of the gorgonites not
long after Christy arrives and assumes
that the store has been robbed so she
assists Alan in cleaning up once they
are done Alan Stuffs the toy into his
backpack and rides his bike home however
he is unaware that the Commando Elite
are pursuing him they throw brick onto
the bike to assassinate Archer but the
plan goes horribly wrong and he ends up
crashing into pieces the Commando Elite
then repairs brick and heads to Allen's
house meanwhile Allen calls the company
to express his displeasure with the
commando's actions but he has only met
with apathy Archer attempts to converse
with Alan but the enraged boy orders him
to shut up and stop talking later at
globotech Erwin discovers Alan's
voicemail complaint so he summons Larry
to discuss the matter he claims that
they cannot have dangerous toys on the
market where they will be forced to
recall the end entire line Larry
eventually caves in and he also reveals
that he had inserted Munitions chips
into the toys assuming it would be a
good fit hearing this Irwin is enraged
and perplexed at the same time he says
you put Munitions chips and toys
elsewhere Alan is asleep in his room
while Archer explores the house a short
time later chip Hazard and the Commando
Elite capture and interrogate him in the
kitchen sink Allen awakens to find the
Soldier's assaulting Archer so he rushes
to save him driving the Commando Elite
Away in the process he also jams Nick
Nitro into the sink destroying him from
the knees down the noise alerts his
parents and they quickly rush to
investigate the commotion however by the
time they arrive Nick Nitro has somehow
dragged himself out of the sink and
escaped meanwhile after being caught
Alan is forced to confess his illegal
acquisition of the toys the
parent-to-sun discussion escalates into
a heated argument when Allen asserts
that the toys were responsible for the
missing tools leading his parents to
suspect he might be taken smack shortly
after Ellen storms into his room and
angrily confronts Archer for his lack of
support he demands to know why Archer
didn't speak and prove to his parents
that the toys are alive in response the
gorgonite leader repeats Allen's earlier
command to shut up after the two sort
out their differences they look at the
bigger picture and start devising a
strategy to locate the other gorgonites
before the Commando Elite do on the
other hand the Commando Elite congregate
in Christie's garage next door where
chip Hazard delivers a stirring
incoherent speech to his followers soon
Nick crawls into the garage and perishes
and ships arms because of this the
enraged group decides to seek Vengeance
on Allen they start their plan by
converting all the Sharp Tools
electronics and other Hardware into
makeshift vehicles and miniature weapons
of mass destruction the next day Allen
returns to the store and wonders where
the gorgonites are hiding after a bit of
thinking he realizes that they must be
in the trash as it is the only place
where the enemies won't suspect them so
he rushes to the dumpster behind the
store and encounters the rest of
Archer's team thereafter they use Alan's
computer to locate their imagined
homeland of Gorgon back at globotech
Erwin and Larry speak with the
scientists who invented the
microprocessor the latter claims that
the chips are nearly perfect and that
they can develop intelligence through
learning the only flaw appears to be a
flow that can be destroyed by an
electromagnetic pulse meanwhile the
Commando Elite Taps into the phone lines
and eavesdrops on Alan and Christie's
innocent flirtation Link's static is
looking baked they then complete
developing their weapons and set out for
their mission at Christie's Place her
parents are settling in for a night in
front of their brand new high-tech TV
set the Commando Elite secretly enter
the room and administer a few roofies
into the couple's drinks causing them to
fall asleep in no time the soldiers then
proceed to Christie's room where they
find timay and quickly tie him up before
throwing him into the closet after this
they find Christy's doll collection and
come up with a devious thirsty plan they
implant Nick nitro's chip into the
brains of each of the Dolls turning them
into an army of violent zombies a short
while later Christy's boyfriend drops
her off at home upon heading towards her
bedroom Christy is shocked when she
discovers the Assembly of zombie dolls
they drag her down by her feet and bind
her causing her to scream for help
hearing her cries her BF rushes to her
Aid and he even manages to defeat a few
dolls but just then the Commandos arrive
and fire a flamethrower at him causing
him to retreat whatever babe you
wouldn't put out anyway the Commando
Elite then forces Christy to make a
hostage video demanding the gorgonites
surrender when the video reaches Alan he
wastes no time and starts planning a
counter-attack in the next scene he
leaves a large box labeled gorgonites in
front of Christy's house this distracts
the Commandos so Alan dashes to the
backyard and launches a rocket sending
Archer parachuting into the house Archer
then unlocks the back door and lets his
friend Zan following this they proceed
to Christy's room fight the zombie dolls
and eventually set her free because of
this heroic act Christy is greatly
impressed and to show her gratitude she
kisses Alan whoa outside the Commandos
go through a lengthy procedure and cause
an explosion in the Box only to realize
that it's just a decoy as a result they
drive out of the garage and pursue
Christy Allen and Archer who are fleeing
on a motor scooter during the chase all
the Commandos crash into a pond and get
destroyed except for the resilient chip
Hazard who manages to survive despite
having a part of his face melted after
he reaches a nearby toy store and he
hijacks a delivery of new Commando elite
figures and forces the driver Joe to
take him to Allen's house on the other
hand Alan and the Gang arrive at his
place where his parents are arguing
about recent events shortly after Larry
and Irwin also arrive and confirm that
the toys have actually come to life
hearing this an enraged Stewart's smacks
Larry across the face claiming that the
toys nearly killed my son suddenly the
lights go out and when Alan peeks
through the window he notices a large
Army of Evil toys approaching them chip
Hazard mobilizes dozens of Commandos and
declares war on the gorgonites and their
human allies by unleashing Nails flaming
tennis balls and even firework Rockets
the humans are in a state of panic until
Erwin and Larry remember that an
electromagnetic pulse can disable the
microchip in the Commandos Alan
desperate for a source suggests climbing
up to the two Transformers outside
infusing them with a metal tool which
would result in an overload and an
erupting magnetic field Larry and Irwin
confirmed that the plan would work and
they also reveal that the gorgonites
will not survive the blast hearing this
Ellen hesitates for a bit but when
Archer mentions that it's for the
greater good he sets out to finish the
task he then climbs up the electric pole
but ship Hazard chases him in a toy
helicopter and starts shooting at him
fortunately the gorgonites take control
of one of the vehicles and use its
weapon to shoot down the helicopter
before it crashes into a satellite chip
Hazard manages to jump out and land on
the electric pole he attempts to knock
Allen down but right then Archer arrives
and the two get into a brutal fight
unfortunately Archer is no match for the
Commando leader and he is eventually
defeated and pushed from the pole in
retaliation Alan grabs Hazard and jams
him between the Transformers this
activates the EMP and causes a large
explosion which finally destroys the
Commando Elite and their doll allies the
next morning the CEO of globotech
gilmars arrives at the scene and bribes
all the witnesses to the crisis into
silence Larry is apprehensive about
losing his job but Mars suggests that
they raise the price of the Commando
Elite and sell them to a South American
country's military meanwhile Allen is
devastated that he has lost his
gorgonite friends forever as he cleans
up the mess with teary eyes suddenly he
discovers Archer's bow he quickly lifts
up the toppled Satellite Dish and
becomes elated to find that all the
gorgonites are alive it turns out that
they sheltered themselves inside the
dish because of which they survived the
EMP impact in the final scene the
gorgonite say their goodbyes to Alan and
embark on a quest to find their Homeland
Gorgon on Stewart's model ship it's a
good thing they've got places to be
thanks Alan me and Christy are gonna
need some alone time
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching